voilà pour ces sorties ciné et
j'accueille sur ce plateau c'est une
première il ya deux piscines pour soit
venu en plateau c'est avec vous que nous
allons nous intéresser à la culture
dorénavant chaque mercredi et trois
invités vous ne fait pas les choses à
moitié pour cette première tout à fait
il ce soir nous recevons donc pour
parler la troisième édition du jam
battle contest qui aura lieu à trappes
ce week end samedi
donc nous recevons les membres
organisateurs
alors je vais vous laisser vous
présenter nos excuses déjà en premier
parce qu'ils ont donc l'association
stricte hip hop pour l'organisation du
8e battle conteste surtout sur la partie
aspects financiers subvention peut être
pour l'organisation de l'événement et de
et de le démon de l'association en
général d'accord on va revenir après sur
justement les rôles de chacun tu restes
un titre cette vice président de
l'association au strict hip hop je sais
le président de l'association
je m'occupe de tout ce qui concerne pas
l'évènement ça soit les pour ce qui va
en venir
pour les renseignements pour pour tout
ce qui concerne le bateau langon
vous êtes tous les trois dans faire
participer aussi aux batailles de notre
nous et deux d'entre eux participent à
ces opérations
on est dans la même équipe donc ça ne
sera pas en compétition d'un contre 2,3
alors justement expliqué nous qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un john battle test ça
consiste en quoi
donc j'en battais le contest c'est un
événement de danse hip hop donc dans les
pop il ya un autre parti à nous c'est le
breakdance donc c'est toutes les figures
acrobatiques peut que vous pouvez voir
sur les mains ou tourner sur la tête le
match qu'on n'est pas la place sur ce
plateau c'était sympa ouais je fais
comme ça il fait une démo
oui ça s'appelle un bizutage bienvenus
il ya des filles qui dans ce genre de
table ça m'apprendra venir voir donc en
fait ça consiste en plusieurs équipes
qui s'affrontent l'une contre l'autre
pour gagner la première place et nous on
offre 400 euros au gagnant
voilà donc c'est une compétition avec un
prix ce sera donc un jury alors
expliquez nous le jury se compose de qui
comment vous l'avez recruter alors il ya
un jury qui sera composé de trois
personnes
ben eager du week-end qui elle tend ce
depuis un certain temps et organiser le
même sens propre événement qui est
marraine également de notre événement bi
et le troisième c'est la hausse est donc
chacun à pau sa discipline dans la
musicalité l'autre dans le style l'autre
dans la technique et des pins sont
desservis au groupe qui a plus excellé
dans la discipline et on comptabilise
nom de points au final et celui qui en a
le plus remporté le battle en lui-même
d'accord mon clan voit justement
quelques images de l'édition précédente
alors c'est très facile ça a l'air
facile je suppose que c'est beaucoup de
travail et en effet et alors troisième
édition
quelles sont les nouveautés cette année
bon déjà les équipes les équipes seront
seront différents
on avait plus privilégiés l'année
dernière toutes les équipes qui se situe
dans l'étude de france mais cette année
on a de la chance d'accueillir des
belges
même des certains danseurs algériens
marocains et n'a voulu un peu touché un
peu hors de la france pour pour le
public surtout et pour nous aussi pour
ça nous ferait plaisir de badens et
contre
des personnes extérieures de l'onu de
france et j'ai cru comprendre la
spécificité aussi c'est comme ça que
vous demandez cette année c'est un
battle non contre eux sud de battles
entretien battle avec les types fin par
équipes équipe dès 8 ans et plus en
dehors de ça en madiran c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau son maintien tout le monde
attend ça c'est le nord contre sud c'est
un peu comme le paris-marseille au foot
là ce sera le nord contre le sud donc
les sudistes monte roman clairement
tamas et les longues distances
le niveau est le même partout j'ai déjà
au niveau international puisqu'on
parlait de l'international tout à
l'heure le niveau est le même partout il
ya certains pays qui se démarquent
enfin on va dire ça s'équilibre en ça
s'équilibre en ce moment c'est vrai
maintenant à un moment c'était les états
unis des états unis après c'est la
france qui est passé devant parce qu en
fait vers gros il ya un gros aspect
hostile vous savez beaucoup des états
unis après un gros aspect technique dans
l'évolution des choses et donc la france
n'était pas mal là dessus donc on avait
pris les devants et là on a l'impression
que ça revient de plus en plus hostile
donc les états unis et beaucoup l'aller
les asiatiques la corée prendre prennent
énormément de d'envergure sur ce genre
de 10 mais on a eu aussi beaucoup de
demandes avec les pays du brésil les
pays de l'est comme la russie mais
malheureusement il n'avait pas encore eu
assez de niveau enfin montré que le
niveau était pas encore assez bon pour
les accueillir il ya beaucoup de
demandes donc ça commence vraiment à
prendre une grande ampleur le hip hop et
on est fier de ça comme quoi le nord et
le sud juste peut-être le nord et le sud
parce qu'à cette rivalité nord 6 alors
là oui la north débrouille mieux que le
site met d'accord le nord est plus que
dans les yvelines une réponse de l'uci
fait forcément enfin s'adaptent plus
facilement le sud et plus rigoureux et
du coup on peut attendre attendre la
suite on peut savoir ce qu'il va se
passer
il se présente avant tout cas et alors
donc si j'ai bien compris vous fait une
présélection finalement des groupes pour
le battle nord-sud oui en fait parce que
y'a le bateau lui-même
deux des équipes 8 vs vite mais il ya
justement la spécifité spécificité de
cette de ce battle cette année c'est le
nord et le sud
donc on a déjà l'équipe sélectionnée du
sud mais on a invité d'autres danseurs
pour pouvoir effectuer ce qu'on appelle
à un cercle
c'est à dire en aura trois sets c'est à
dire la scène centrale
plus de de cercle sur les côtés pour
pouvoir en tirer les meilleurs danseurs
du nord ont créé cette équipe c'est
dommage mais c'est bien dans le nord on
pouvait pas accueillir tout le monde
heureusement une dizaine de danseurs
pour créer cet équipement qui affrontera
l'équipe du sud en fête
ok d'accord alors qu'elle l'a vous avez
organisé tout ça ce sont quasiment une
année vous avez créé des partenariats
avec qui expliquait nous on travaille
beaucoup avec la mairie trappe
essentiellement qui nous font confiance
disons que sur le sur saint quentin en
yvelines et à 2 battle plus de doute ça
fait 3 donc qui qui se démarque pas mal
et donc on essaie de
de faire bénéficier également de cette
culture hip hop à la ville de trappes et
notre événement donc il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup mis en avant surtout grâce à la
mairie trappe
maintenant au niveau des partenariats on
discute beaucoup avec des death
portuaire de tout ce qui concerne des
habits il ya des personnes qui tiendront
des stands également au niveau de
l'événement et on a sollicité d'autres
sponsors au niveau des boissons
énergisantes mais malheureusement on n'a
pas de réponse pour l'instant
mais je pense que l'année prochaine
quand ils verront l'événement cette
année il a courons à la porte pour toi
pour pouvoir également être être avec
nos projets pour l'événement petit
rappel des dates donc c'est samedi à
partir de 13h30 à la salle jean baptiste
clément à trappes
c'est donc nombreux pour ce match
notamment entre le nord et le sud
voilà merci donc à tous les trois
orléans construire cette page culture
oui tout à fait wilfrid 10 q vous savez
que le café de la plage va réouvrir ses
portes
allons donc ça y est c'est ouvert et oui
après près de deux ans de travaux
rénover tout neuf le café de la plage
donc maintenant fin prêt à accueillir
ces groupes et nous avons rencontré son
directeur
regardez un an et demi de travaux et
voilà le café de la plage transformer
celui de spectacles historiques de
maurepas a fait peau neuve
un espace plus grand 900 m² au total la
création d'une deuxième salle de
spectacle du matériel rénové une
meilleure acoustique et même des espaces
en backstage
comme ces loges qui n'attendent plus que
leurs artistes qu'on se soit oldelaf qui
a beaucoup travaillé sur la scène du
café où les joyeux urbains
jim murple mémorial qui est déjà passé
plusieurs fois sur la structure quoi
vous dire d'autre
arnaud tsamère qui on vient nous faire
le plaisir d'une carte blanche et bien
entendu tous les groupes locaux des
artistes locaux donc et des stars comme
jamel qui a parrainé l'inauguration de
vendredi dernier
la programmation est déjà bouclée
jusqu'en juillet première date le 1er
mars pour chaud l'hiver
un festival avec des artistes membres de
cobalt
le studio d'enregistrement de la ville
un clin d'oeil aux partenariats à venir
avec les différents acteurs jeunesse de
maurepas c'est un projet jeunesse qui va
se développer également sur des projets
transversaux avec les autres structures
jeunesse de la ville
il va y avoir également des projets
intergénérationnels sur cette structure
là et c'est un lieu où on fait de la
prévention également auprès de la
population jeunes de la ville dans cette
optique la toute nouvelle structure
accueille également la boutique infos
jeunes ouverte au public depuis mardi et
il n'est pas de bonne crown culture sans
un petit agenda et wilfrid alors ce week
end
beaucoup d'événements m'a fait une
petite sélection tout d'abord un groupe
qui revient sur le devant de la scène
il s'agit donc de raggasonic qui sera
donc en concert à la batterie à
guyancourt samedi à 20h30 avec un duo
assez exceptionnel ky-mani marley
marleix oui tout à fait ainsi ce fait se
doit de tout à fait donc ça c'est samedi
à 20h30 nous avons aussi du côté de
coignières et ça ce sera pour mardi 5
février un spectacle de marionnettes
donc là plutôt dédié aux enfants à
partir de 3 ans donc un spectacle un
autour d'événements mystérieux qui agite
en fait les membres d'une famille et
enfin on revient à samedi un spectacle
mêlant magie et musique à l'estaminet à
l'occasion de leurs dix ans donc ils
recevront deux artistes tout à fait
exceptionnel donc ça c'est samedi pour
la pensée 3 bat que vous avez
sélectionné pu y aura un autre spectacle
si avoir ce week end et on va voir les
images d'ailleurs tout à fait donc au
théâtre un de 50 ans se joue ce week-end
donc samedi un récital le récital 22h
post scriptum et nous avons rencontré
son metteur en scène 22h post scriptum
la suite des aventures théâtrales
musicales du ring saga en création au
théâtre de saint quentin
ce récital poétique pose ainsi la
question qu'est devenu le personnage de
wotan une fois sorti du ring de richard
wagner
la réponse émane tout droit de
l'imaginaire et de l'histoire d'amitié
entre le metteur en scène antoine gindt
et le baryton à ivan ludlow évidemment
il continue sa vie d'artiste chante
autre chose hélas totalement à partir de
ce fils un peu banal on peut tirer tout
a tant d'histoire parce qu est-ce qui
chantent
et c'est là dessus qu'on commence notre
histoire à nous de savoir qu'est-ce que
high value de l'eau qui font wotan qui
était vendeur et maintenant comment il
revient avec quelle chanson hébreu de la
relation fondatrice de ce projet qui lie
le chanteur et sa pianiste à la vie
comme à la scène transporte un civet
public vers une authentique complicité
au delà d'un simple récital piano voix
le metteur en scène antoine gindt a
souhaité apporter dimension plus
théâtral une forme revisitée mêlant
images et technologies la mise en scène
contemporaine très libre nous donne à
entendre pour la première fois en france
des poèmes de nietzsche mise en musique
sur des airs de wagner de rim ou des
mélodies décalé
évidemment quand on pense souvent
d'horreur on pense aux voyageurs et
quand on pense aux voyageurs enfin pour
ma génération encore peut-être on se dit
tiens il ya une chanson qui résonne à
nos oreilles c'est ça le wild hog le
storm des doors et on s'est dit tiens
comment on peut introduire ce ce
décalage
je pense qu'on a pour antoine gindt ce
spectacle relève surtout d'une certaine
méditation d'un voyage vers le
cheminement de la pensée en musique en
représentation les 1er et 2 février au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
voilà pour cette chronique culture merci
aurélien la semaine prochaine s'il ya
une date à retenir pour ce week-end pour
sortir c'est peut-être le concert votre
sélection c'est quoi le concert de
raggasonic
ah oui je pense que c'est vraiment le
coup donc c'est à la batterie ce week
end merci